what do we know about the liverpool
attack
well clearly it's an emerging situation
and the home secretary is being kept
briefed on it you will have seen it's
been reported that three people have
been arrested under counterterrorism
offences clear it's an ongoing
investigation so there's a limit to what
i can say on it but as the prime
minister said last night and i very much
say his deep sympathy for the person
that's lost their life and the
injuries that have been sustained in
this
extraordinary um an appalling attack to
do so uh at a hospital and it's a
reminder to us all that the the threat
of terrorism hasn't gone away and how
much we depend on our police and
security services as you say it's
developing situation but
there is a lot of
speculation in fact there's a photograph
of a cabbie who apparently locked
someone into a vehicle and managed to
get away but he has been um injured he's
now seriously in hospital i mean if
that's the case such bravery um that
potentially saves so many lives
well isn't that the case the contrast
between the the cowardice of uh
terrorist attacks and the bravery of
ordinary britons up and down the country
who who put other people's lives uh
before their their own clearly will have
to see exactly what happened there but
if that that is the case that's another
example of of true bravery and courage
absolutely any plans at the stage to
raise the alert level
uh well that that is a matter for the
the home secretary and uh the joint
intelligence committee based on uh
evidence i think that this sort of
attack is consistent with the existing
uh terror level but clearly that is kept
under removed by the government okay um
and of course we'll hear more about it
throughout the course of the day what we
do know is that there were uh moving on
to covered 448 000 boosters given
yesterday it's really ratcheting up now
um when will the jab be rolled out for
um as one of my colleagues said the
younger age group in other words the
over 50s
i think
we're progressing through the um through
their business unless you said we
actually made very good progress i think
we're now at a 12 million two million
jobs in the past week uh there will be a
further announcement uh from jcvi that's
the independent uh committee later today
on the rollout of booster jabs clear
it's up to them but i would hope that we
would see a further expansion of booster
rollouts uh but we'll wait for their
announcements so that's the jcvi they're
the people that advise the government
and they're going to make a further
announcement this morning yes so so
we're expecting a further announcement
from them uh outlining what what the
next steps are clearly their independent
government but uh yeah we uh we would
hope the government that they will be
advising us for with further progress
yeah okay this i mean there is less than
six hours we were looking this morning
less than six weeks to christmas can you
believe it um what are your predictions
for any restrictions leading up to
christmas well really okay it's in our
hands so all of us all of your viewers
um if you get the booster when the call
comes that is the biggest wall of
defense that we have against covert and
if you look at some of the numbers uh at
the end of october infection numbers
were roughly comparable to where they
were mid-january last year if you
remember that was really at the height
of it last year but hospitalizations
were 74 lower now that shows you the
power of the vaccine so i'm confident
that if we stick the course if people
take the the boosters uh when they're
asked to do so that vaccine wall will
hold up and we'll be able to have a
decent christmas this year i mean we're
looking at countries like austria just
across the channel and they are saying
if you've not had your vaccine and your
booster you have to stay at home we're
locking you in other people who are
fully vaccinated can go about their
business is that something that we might
look at
that's not something we're currently
contemplating of course it is the case
although it's an entirely separate
matter that in relation to very high
risk areas such as care homes we are
requiring people to have those those
double jabs it's always been the british
tradition i think to to move on a
consensual voluntary basis so we have no
plans to
to have that kind of differentiated
approach between the vaccines and
non-vaccine but it is so essential
because it's if you take the further
vaccine it's good for you so it protects
your own health but it also protects
everyone else's health because there's a
lower risk of catching the disease and
therefore transmitting it yeah although
it's not consensual if you work for the
nhs is it because you're changing the
rules there
well yes but that that is in a specific
um
situation where you're an employee and
you're dealing with very very high-risk
people
i wonder if i could just go back to
chris christmas just for a second
because i know that we you know we we
were in a similar position this time
last year when we were saying christmas
you can have christmas with your family
etc and then two days before the rules
were changed
you just said that it's in our hands so
we do we really do need to make sure
that we have these boosters when we're
called or potentially we could find
ourselves in a challenging position
again well the way we avoid a
challenging position is to take the
boost i can assure you there are no
plans or anything else to to to stop
christmas happening but the way you can
guarantee me did you say that but no but
the huge difference this time kay is the
vaccine and the huge impact of the
vaccine and the way we keep that vaccine
topped up the way that we keep that that
wall of defense protected
is get your booster when you get the the
call up because if you compare to where
we were last year
zero people had the vaccine we're now at
around 89 90 percent of people adults
with with the vaccine so that is what is
protecting us from going back to what we
had at christmas but we have to keep
that protection a top top by taking the
booster do we need to be aware of what's
happening the other side of the channel
though and and potentially we could see
travel restrictions given just how high
the numbers are although in germany
they're working from home and their
numbers are lower than ours
well what's happening across the channel
is a constant reminder that this global
pandemic hasn't gone away
this country's approach to the pandemic
is to make sure that we have high levels
of vaccine protection so that's that's
why we keep pushing the message on the
vaccine so i think that that is the most
appropriate approach for this country
although we have had heard criticism
previously for the government not
protecting our borders not closing down
quickly enough and as a result we find
ourselves in a position where we've had
to lock down well yes well of course we
keep keep these things under review all
the time you've seen that we have moved
away from some of those restrictions we
haven't ruled it out and of course if
the situation changes dramatically we
would have to to review that again but
but as as i say and i'm forgiving to
keep coming back to the point but really
the big thing we're doing in this
country is to have the vaccine program
that is what is protecting us from all
those risks that toppled us off course
this time last week what would change
dramatically look like
well well we see if we have um
for example a new variant uh emerging we
would have to consider what our borders
would look like in that situation to
to protect us as we have done in the
past but
i'm confident if you listen to people
like the chief medical officer if you
listen to the chief scientific advisor
they are confident in the government's
approach of putting
our faith in the vaccine program and so
far that has worked if you remember back
in the 19th of july all that debate
about should we open should we close uh
for example kirsten was saying let's not
have this this final phase of reopening
we're only able to do that because of
the vaccine program we said we had
confidence in it and actually that
proved to be the right call um
astrazeneca is um saying that they're
going to start owning a modest profit
from their vaccine previously sold at
cost what's the government's view on
that
well i think
drug companies like astrozemic who've
invested huge amounts of of money into
the vaccine program are entitled to have
a profit from their investment actually
if you look at the oxford astrozenica
model and contrast it to others around
the world the number of a very very low
cost doses that are made available to
particularly to developing countries
is an exemplary model
but is it right that they charge um
they're about to start making a profit
well i think it's it's up to astrazeneca
as a commercial company to be able to
make a modest profit on what it was a
huge investment but i think it's also
worth noting that the model that they
have has allowed lots of low-cost
vaccines to be distributed globally in
developing countries
well actually i mean south africa and
the like um i can't recall the the ha
the figures off the top of my head but i
think we're at now tens of millions of
vaccines that have been made available
from the uk to developing countries it's
always been part of the government's
approach not just to protect people here
but also to get vaccines to developing
countries can we ask about belarus and
poland just quickly if i may i know it's
not necessarily your area of expertise
but you're here representing the
government this morning are you worried
that belarus could escalate into
something really quite serious with
british troops quite nearby
well british troops are in uh eastern
europe for example we have a large
numbers of them uh in estonia uh
to offer our our guarantee and
protection as part of
nato to um to protect nato countries uh
in in eastern europe the uk
invests more in defense than pretty much
any in fact more than any other european
country is a proportion of our gdp we
stand ready to protect our partners and
to uphold peace and security in europe
yeah but how worried are we about what's
happening on the border with poland well
it's um it's a worrying situation but i
think it's
as i understand as you say is not
directly my brief but the situation is
currently under
uh control but there's there's a great
deal of attention being paid to it
by by the government we keep the the
whole situation uh under review but as i
say our contribution as as the united
kingdom is to the the defense and and
stability of europe that has continued
uh despite us leaving the european union
it's more important than ever that we we
protect europe and we have got troops
there to help do that yeah so we're not
we're not
really concerned at the moment despite
the fact that there are um thousands and
thousands and thousands of desperate
people clamoring to try and get over
that ball well yes it's besides the same
you know yeah it's a very um it's very
worrying situation as
as i said and that's why the government
keeps it
under very close review and it's very
much at the top of the agenda for the
prime minister and the the defense
secretary
and um our our military assets are are
available there but as i said at the
moment uh it's a worrying situation but
we are we're keeping it under okay
something else that you're keeping under
review is what's happening with sleaze i
mean that really got away from you guys
didn't it
well the the prime minister um said
yesterday and we've said uh yes we we
made some mistakes we would have done
things differently and and we've said we
regret that
he hasn't said his story though
well
i think i think you begin to argue about
uh semantics on this i think the prime
minister the promise has said that
he regrets it he said that mistakes are
made but really the prime minister's
focus is is actually and look what he's
been doing over the weekend with uh the
the climate change summit the huge
progress we've made there uh further
announcements today on the the booster
program i think what people want now
they they accept what we said which is
we made mistakes they want this
government actually to be focusing on
the job at hand and that's exactly what
we're doing tackling huge challenges
like uh global warming securing the
future for our children our
grandchildren indeed our children's
children our grandchildren's
grandchildren these are the big
long-term decisions that are being made
by the government and i'm sure i see the
prime minister pretty much every day and
certainly speak to him every day that is
where his focus is understand that and
you know we covered that extensively
throughout the last two weeks here on
sky news but um the point is that the
prime minister has not said sorry you
for the first time are the the party six
points behind labor in the polls that
has not been seen while kyocerma has
been in office and that is the public
giving you guys a bloody nose saying
don't treat us like we're mugs because
we are not the least you can do is say
sorry and say that you didn't mean to
undermine the standard system even if
that's what you did well the the prime
minister has said that we've made
mistakes and that he he regrets that i
think that that's effectively
saying the same thing we've accepted
that we're going to pursue a different
course and actually you'll see that from
the motion that's before parliament
today that we're accepting the the
standards recommendation indeed owen
patterson has uh resigned as a member of
parliament but you talk about how the
the public feel about it i really think
and this is my my sense both from all
the polls and from conversations that i
i have with people as as party chairman
they want the government to be focused
on getting on with the job that they
don't want the government to be
distracted by other things obviously
they don't want them to be slaves yes of
course um
and we all have to uphold the high
standards in in in public life
but but we have to demonstrate that we
are delivering for people that's what
we're doing and delivering tackling
climate change we're delivering with
billions of pounds extra for our nhs
we're delivering with improvements for
the economy that's what governments are
elected to do and certainly my focus and
the government's focus is on getting on
with that job how's the new job going
i'm enjoying it enormously thank you
lots of challenges but i'm enjoying it
enormously a round of press interviews
to go so i better let you go it's good
to talk to you as well thank you very
much